la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue philippe dallier pour le groupe
l'est républicain pour deux minutes
résidence
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
garde des sceaux elle concerne également
le tribunal de grande instance de
bobigny bobigny deuxième juridictions de
france après paris quarante mille
affaires nouvelles par an au civil 40000
au pénal pour faire face à cette masse
de dossiers et même si beaucoup les juge
insuffisants les effectifs sont là en
tous les cas ils sont là sur le papier
mais en réalité 20 % de postes de
magistrats du siège et du parquet et à
peu près autant aux greffes sont vacants
les délais d'audiencement sont
aujourd'hui devenus absolument
insupportable quatorze mois pour une
audience en conciliation dans une
affaire de divorce entre trois mois à
paris cinq mois à lyon
concernant les mineurs 400 mesures
éducatives sont en attente d'exécution
ça n'est pas bon pour le sentiment
d'impunité de ces jeunes
ça n'est pas bon pour la récidive au
pénal des affaires de délinquance
organisée et de trafic de stupéfiants
sont parfois jugés jusqu'à six ans après
les faits et que dire des conditions
dans lesquelles la justice est rendue au
tribunal d'instance une audience dure en
moyenne six minutes plaidoirie comprise
faute de personnel le président du tgi
vient de décider effectivement de
réduire de 20% le nombre des audiences
et nul ne saurait l'en blâmer mais dans
ce département si fragile les délais
d'audiencement vont donc encore
s'allonger et la réponse pénale faiblir
faisant encore un peu plus reculées
la notion d'égalité de traitement des
citoyens devant la loi monsieur le
ministre que comptez vous faire pour
remédier à cette situation et surtout
dans quel délai pensez vous que la
situation puisse revenir à la normale
quand vous répondre la parole est au
garde des sceaux jean jacques urvoas
vous avez la parole
oui monsieur le sénateur que je cherche
toujours voilà excusez-moi j'ai dit tout
à l'heure ce que je pensais de bobigny
je pense que c'est une suite c'est une
situation qui est en souffrance et qui
n'est évidemment pas acceptable de
penser que l'on peut aujourd'hui avoir
sur le papier
cent soixante dix sept magistrats et
n'en avoir que 154 à l'effectif donc
nous avons deux problèmes
en réalité même trois le premier
problème c'est que nous sommes en
sous-effectif pas plus dans cette
juridiction qu'ailleurs j'ai dit ce que
le gouvernement faisait
nous recrutons mais il faut trente et un
mois pour qu'un magistrat puisse arriver
donc il faut trouver d'autres solutions
je vais en parler avec le président le
breton de vanoise vendredi et madame
klein de natick et la procureure sous
l'autorité du premier président de la
cour d'appel et de la procureure
générale de la cour d'appel
deuxième problème ou un problème
d'attractivité parce que quand les
commandes quand les magistrats viennent
à bobigny il n'y reste pas donc il faut
que nous regardions à nouveau là aussi
mais je ne peux pas le faire en deux
jours la manière dont nous trouvons
indiciaire mans une réponse assure le
troisième problème est un problème
d'environnement c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai annoncé vendredi à
chartres que je réorientait 14 millions
d'euros pour remplacer pour créer des
postes de vacation rapide pour décharger
et les magistrats et les greffes de
façon à ce qu'il se concentre sur ce qui
est leur métier ils ont besoin de cela
c'est en tout cas le message qu'ils
m'ont fait passer
j'ai engagé ma prédécesseure l'avait
commencé une réflexion sur un contrat
d'objectifs avec la direction des
services judiciaires avec le président
du tgi aussi mais ce n'est pas suffisant
parce que cela demandera du temps
j'espère que nous aurons très rapidement
des réponses urgentes merci monsieur
d'allier monsieur le président ce
ministre la situation du tj de bobigny
n'a jamais été excellentes mais en 2011
des postes de magistrats et greffiers
ont été créés
la situation s'était améliorée elle sert
détériorée depuis 18 mois environ et
nous atteignons l'inacceptable ce
département plus que tout autre a besoin
d'une justice efficace et rapide
sinon nous ne sortirons pas ce
département de la seine-saint-denis de
l'ornière dans laquelle il est jusqu'à
présent
merci